All right, everybody. So here is the last chapter of the FAS, SMC, VIP course. And
in this chapter, I'm going to teach you the how to trade the AR50 or the Asian range 50%
trading strategy that I taught on Twitter before. But I didn't teach you how to trade it with
daily bias and what techniques I used to increase the win rate. This is going to be a complete guide.
So watch very carefully. This is not going to be uploaded on YouTube or anywhere else. And this
is going to be exclusive for the members only. And the other strategy that I taught you in this
update are also going to be exclusive. So I'm going to I want to give a shout out to T trades and the
market maker trader, the MMX some Twitter. They teach this really good on how to find your
you know, the bias. Now this is not exactly the bias, but the direction. And by using this technique,
you'll be able to trade the air 50 the right way with very high probability with very high win rate.
So look at this green candle. And I'm on the daily time from now. Initially, I would want if I
want to be bullish, if I want to be bullish, I would want the next daily candle to close above it,
to close above this high. Now, if it closes, we can then be bullish. But what happened here,
we get a rejection. Okay. So now for me to be bearish. Once I get the rejection, right, the body didn't
close. Now, there's a chance that we could be bearish. So to confirm that, I want the next daily
candle to close below the slope. And what happens? It didn't close. And we got a rejection straight
off it. So now our bias is not clear. Now, this is a bullish candle. So I want the other the next
candle to close above it. Right. And over here, we have a close. So now, here's what you have to
do from here. Once the candle closes above the green candle, this high is going to be your draw
on liquidity. Price is going to take out this high 80 to 90% of the time. Well, that's actually
a lot, but 80% of the time. So now once you have the closure here, you can be bullish with AR50
trading strategy. And notice what happens. Price takes out that high. And once again, we close
above this. So now what's going to happen? We have another high. And this is going to be a
draw on liquidity. And notice what happens. Price, first of all, gives us a power of three. Or in
otherwise, this is going to be a Asian range pullback to 50% of the level. Right. And we close once
again. So now we're going to be bullish. And this is going to be our take profit draw on liquidity,
the daily previous day high. And once again, we take out the high over here, and we close above
it. So now this high is going to be our draw on liquidity. This is going to be our target. So
we're going to stay bullish. And right here, once we took out the high, right, once the draw
on liquidity was hit, we had a rejection. So now since the body didn't close above it, we are now
in a phase one, we have to wait for price to either break this or break this that would confirm the
bias. So nothing happens. We get a rejection once again. But then what do we have? We have a body
closure once again, right? So now this is going to be our target level. This is going to be a draw
on liquidity. So now we can trade the air 50 to be bullish. We're going to trade, we're going to
only take the long position. And notice what happens. Price pulls back gives us a power of three,
and then goes up. Now, once again, we closed above it. So now what's going to happen?
The daily high is going to be our take profit level. And right here, once you can see that
the take profit level, sorry, the draw on liquidity was hit, we now closed below this candle. So now,
this is going to be our draw on liquidity. But then you can see that price consolidated,
and nothing happened. And right once again, we have since so once this you might have experienced
a losing trade here, because the body closed below this, but we we might have got on one loss,
it's not going to be like 100% win rate. So now over here, we failed to close above it. So we are
still not doing anything. And right here, what you can see, we closed above the daily candle.
So now this is going to be our take profit level. And right here, it was hit. And once again,
we closed above it. We had a power of three look at this week, right? This is going to be
an Asian range entry. And that's when the target was hit. So now this daily high is going to be
our take profit level. Sorry, draw on liquidity keeps saying take profit level, but price is
going to go. So now after price takes out the high, now we what we have, we have a rejection.
So for me to be bearish, I want to see this level broken. And right here, you can see that the body
closed below this. So now we are bearish. And our target level is going to be this low.
And right here, you can see that the low was taken out, right? And we also closed below this low. So
now we're going to stay bearish. And there's going to be a draw on liquidity. And right again,
once again, we close below it. So now this daily low is going to be our draw on liquidity.
Once again, beautiful. Now here, we also have a low. So this is going to be our drawn liquidity.
And boom, once again, but now the body didn't close. So now we are in a guessing game, we are
not doing anything. So right here, what do we have? We closed above the bullish candle. So this is
going to be our drawn liquidity right here. Boom, right there. Okay. Now once you have this, we closed
once again, above it. So now this is going to be our draw on liquidity. And boom, hit once again,
then we have this high, we closed above this high. So now our draw on liquidity is going to be this
daily high. And boom, once again, we take out this high over here, but we failed to close above it.
So now we are in a guessing game, we are not doing anything. Still in a guessing game,
nothing happened here. Again, in a guessing game, nothing happened.
Still nothing. So we are consolidating in this range, we are not closing below any wake. So we
not doing anything. But then we broke this. And now our bias is going to be this high.
Draw on liquidity is going to be this high. And boom, just like that. And we broke this again,
the high of the day is going to be our drawn liquidity once again, hit. But now we didn't close. So
we are still in a guessing game, we didn't close again. But then once again, what happens,
we closed above it. And this is going to be our drawn liquidity once again. Nothing happens here.
And we might have experienced another losing trade. But now it is today, 26th,
actually, it was on Friday and it's currently weekend. And we closed here. So now my, my, my,
actually, for the next 100, my drawn liquidity is going to be this low. So I have given you
billions of examples right now. And by now, it should be clear to you what I was teaching you.
If you didn't understand, we watched the video again and again. And remember one thing,
it's not going to happen like 100% of the time, but this is going to give you like the bias 80%
of the time 80 to 90% of the time. Trust me on this. All right. So now that I've
teach a new thought to you how to actually find your bias for air 50. Now let me show you a complete
way on how I would trade by having a draw on liquidity and also trading the Asian range.